- Hey, everyone.
What's up?
I wanted to record this short little video
because I've been thinking a bit
about some other ways
in which I might be able to reach students
with my courses and my teaching in R.
And so in particular there's,
so my course, the way that it works now,
it's a self-paced online
prerecorded course.
When you sign up, you
get the course forever.
You can follow it whenever
you want at your own pace.
That's the whole point.
But for some people that just
doesn't really work so well.
It, for some people,
they need a little bit more structure
or like a deadline, a goal,
more of the sort of traditional format
where you have a course
and you meet certain number of times.
You have regular weekly meetings
and a particular time
when you know the course is gonna be done.
For some people,
they prefer that type of structure.
So long story short,
I wanted to think about
opening up a few other ways
in which I can offer my
course and my teachings.
And so one idea is to offer
a one-on-one coaching system,
where we meet a certain number of times,
maybe work through the
course material together,
and together we can set goals
for when you want to complete the course.
And by meeting regularly with me,
we can make sure that
you're meeting those goals,
answer any questions along the way,
and really help you learn R
in sort of that more structured format.
So another method,
another idea might be to have
sort of do the same
thing but with a group.
So a group of people, maybe
go through the lessons
in a live sort of manner, meeting
within a regular schedule,
and working through the
course material that way.
That's another option.
So, but I'm also open to any
ideas that you might have.
And, that's why I wanted to
make this video out there.
So if you have any suggestions for ways
in which the course
material could be structured
or presented, whether it's me one-on-one,
or maybe you sign up for the course
and you get the material
regularly sort of dripped
to you every week.
I just wanna get more feedback on,
especially from people
that might be interested
in doing some kind of a
one-on-one or group coaching.
My end goal again, is to help you learn R.
So if you're not sure.
If you've been frustrated
and you feel like R is
kind of overwhelming demon
that you have to get over in order
to get through your dissertation
to get through grad school,
or even just to be a good
scientist in general.
But if it creates kind of that impediment,
kind of invokes that
feeling of anxiety in you,
my goal is to help you get rid of that.
And whether it's through the
self-paced course that I have,
or whether you would like
to work together one or one,
or as part of a group, whatever
method works best for you,
I want to know about it
so that I can try to make
those offerings available
and make those those systems available
so that no matter where you're at
or what learning style you
have, I can help you out.
So with that, I've been rambling a bit,
but I hope the message
is clear and let's see.
Let me make sure I didn't miss anything.
Ah, very important.
If any of these things
sound interesting to you,
in particular group coaching
or one-on-one coaching
or any other kind of new methodology
for how I can teach you R,
there is a little
landing page that I made,
a little place where
you can put your email
to sign up and learn more
when I make these offerings available.
So yeah, just the link
should be down below
in the description.
I don't know where this video will be,
but the link should
be, it should be clear.
So with that,
I'm gonna sign out
and hope you have a
great rest of your day.
All right. Take care.